جريمه هازت الشارع الالماني بعد ان اقدم
شابه المانيه من اصول عراقيه تبلغ من
العمر 23 عاما على قتل شابه تشبهها لكي
تدعي وفاتها
في السادس عشر من اغسطس عام 2022 عثر على
جثه فتاه تبلغ من العمر 23 عاما قتلت
طعنان داخل سياره
في البدايه اعتقد المحققون ان الضحيه هي
ملكه السياره بعد ان اكدت عائلتها التعرف
عليها ولكن في اليوم التالي وبعد تشريح
الجثه اتضح ان الضحيه امراه اخرى وان
القتيله المزعومه حيه ترزق
[موسيقى]
الشرطه وبعد التحقيقات استطاعت ان تكشف
خطوط الجريمه فالشابه التي لا تزال على
قيد الحياه رتبت مؤامره القتل بمساعده
شريك لها وبحثت على الانترنت عن امراه
تشبهها لقتلها ووضعها بطريقه توحي انها
جثتها
وتواصلت مع عدد من الشبات التي يمكن ان
يفينا بالغرض نظرا الى كونهن يشبهنها
وحاولت عبر حسابتهن على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اقنعهن بمقابلتها من خلال تقديم
وعود كاذبه لهم حتى نجحت بالفعل في
الاتفاق مع الضحيه على لقائها في السادس
عشر من اغسطس
وتوجهت المشتبه بها لاستحاب الشابه
المختاره من منزلها وفي طريق العوده لتدرج
الضحيه للخروج من السياره وجري قتلها في
الغابه بعدد كبير من الطعنات
ولا يزال المشتبه بهما
رهن التوقيف الاحتياطي حتى الان